thank you I'm here to present the award
for best screenplay based on material
previously produced or published which I
was to have had the honor of sharing
with my beautiful and very talented
co-star but as the world knows she's due
to go into production at any moment
herself and I could not ask her to climb
stairs unless of course she wins the
Oscar and she'll crawl up here on all
fours on her own
so when I just sit there and glow as you
do and I'll do the best I can without
you here are the nominees John Irving
they're The Cider House Rules based on
his novel making the orphanages have
actually accrued and everlasting is my
pleasure to Alexander Payne and Jim
Taylor for election from the novel by
Tom perotta
Frank Darabont for the Green Mile
adapted from the novel by Stephen King
Eric Roth and Michael Mann for the
insider based on the Vanity Fair article
the man who knew too much by Marie
Brennan was his cheap scabrous I have to
put my family's welfare on the line here
my friend and what are you putting up
you're putting up words Anthony
Minghella for the talented mr. Ripley
adapted from the novel by Patricia
Highsmith please do I can't face it I
can't face anything anymore
and the Oscar goes to John Irving for
the cider house
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Jonathan and the first time he has
adapted his own material for the screen
well you must be trying to get me to
reconsider my day job I want to thank
the Academy for this honor to a film on
the abortion subject and Miramax for
having the courage to make this movie in
the first place but especially my wife
Janet my children Colin Everett and
Brendan Thank You Brendan for coming all
this way
my best friend David Colicchio the
producer Richard Gladstein the director
plus a hallström with whom I would work
again in a second
and everyone at Planned Parenthood and
the National Abortion Rights League